guys I gotta tell you I feel like I've
been covering the same story over and
over man in power assaults dozens of
women and threatens them into silence
pretty sure we did this one two weeks
ago or am i experiencing the globalists
mind control technique known as deja vu
I prefer to report on something new like
Benghazi or Obama's birth certificate
but I can't get to those exciting new
topics because these depressing things
keep happening the growing movement to
end sexual harassment in the wake of the
Harvey Weinstein scandal more than 300
women now say the director James Toback
sexually harassed them MSNBC is now
announcing political contributor Mark
Halperin will no longer be appearing on
the network after at least five women
have come forward alleging sexual
harassment President George HW Bush
facing allegations from at least three
women who say he touched them
inappropriately Anthony Rapp telling
BuzzFeed house of card star Kevin Spacey
made a sexual advance towards him when
he was just 14 years old story after
story classic Hollywood of course after
Harvey Weinstein blew up Hollywood
couldn't resist a sequel
they have no original ideas and by the
looks of this news right now sexual
harassment will have more installments
than all the Saw movies and Fast and the
Furious ones combined but here's the
thing it's a dynamic multifaceted issue
and these accused men all have different
excuses slash reasons for their actions
reasons like I was pursuing
relationships by putting my dick on
their shoulder it's biologically
impossible for me to hump women's legs
because I have diabetes
no comment except one comment not the
black woman
maybe I did it but also I'm coming out
as gay can we focus on the gay part
please
and America's bad grandpa George HW
Bush's spokesperson said this was his
attempt at humor truly shocking that
this brilliant comedy is not appreciated
by everyone these jokes happen all the
time people in fact one out of every six
women is the victim of a really amazing
joke that she just didn't get I thought
this was a woman's only issue something
that they knitted into hats but
apparently they're asking us men to
weigh in where are the men where the
male voices there should be up to the
male stars what I think is important too
is for the men to speak up as someone
who is 100% a male star I would like to
be part of the conversation and use my
platform responsibly so let me bring out
the people most affected by sexual
harassment Laura gray and Nicole
Thurmond can you guys when you guys go
get me give me Kobe Aaron and Josh
please thank you
what I have a little man chat with these
guys and I want the guys to feel safe to
be as honest as possible with no
repercussions so we are going to
consider this locker room talk now I've
just said the words locker room talk on
the record so this conversation is now
protected under the Access Hollywood Act
of 2016
welcome happy to be here our fellow
citizen journalists Tim can't make it
but he said to let you know he's
overjoyed that he's missing this
understood now guys we need to talk
about the victims most affected by the
revelations of sexual harassment men
these latest accusations have real
consequences mark halperin lost his
Showtime deal Harvey Weinstein had to go
to Arizona for a week and
Netflix just pulled the plug on house of
cards leaving us nowhere to go for high
stakes presidential drama / comedy short
this whole situation has me very
confused what are the rules now am I
allowed to look at a woman talk to a
woman wink at a woman can I even call my
mom yes now Mike Pence had a great
solution just never be alone with a
woman unless your wife is present but
then my wife left me so what am I
supposed to bring to business meetings
because my wedding photos where I cut
out her face just creeps everybody out
oh we can totally relate to this issue
believe it or not yeah we touch women's
boobs all the time and it's okay for us
because we're gay and gay misogyny is
called fun yeah but now all of a sudden
fun results in suspension without pay
plus I have to go to awareness training
okay men are under attack yes I mean
women have so much power recently it's
like they could ruin our careers if we
don't do what they want
should one gender have that much power
over the other women are wielding this
power unfairly to force men to act out
their kinkiest fantasy to be left alone
you know all these assaults must have
they must have something in common some
sort of pattern like an inherent power
structure but you know not that
something else yeah powerful men
everywhere are living in fear Jordan our
lives could be over in the blink of a 78
person class-action lawsuit oh hey guys
sorry I'm late Tim here I'm Tim you're
you're Tim what are you talking about
Jordan of course I'm Tim I'm from Joliet
Illinois
I ride a jet ski when I dream and my
favorite color is hot pockets yeah
that's taken up checks out yeah that
totally takes that yeah that's
definitely Ted yeah guys I've been
thinking and what if we don't grab
someone or have sex with them unless
they want it but how would we know when
they want it maybe like if they said it
out loud clearly like they said a verbal
yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes like a like a special
word that they could say like a code
word that's simple understandable by all
sexes so there's like no
misunderstanding you know but what could
that word be it could be yes yeah okay
so I hear what you're proposing we do
and I want to do it too but what is the
word that can allow that to happen yes
it needs to be short and clipping yes
but also yes but also everyone needs to
understand dad so the word you're
looking for is yes God Tim calm down we
know you like the idea a lot of great
ideas here guys
[Music]